Hi everybody.
Welcome to another edition
of YouTube Developers Live.
My name's Ikai Lan.
And today I'm going to
be showing you a trick
that I use when I'm
writing Java code that
makes YouTube data and
YouTube Analytics API calls.
So why don't we go ahead
and switch or my screen?
So if you've ever implemented
OAuth authorization
in your code, you know
that this is something
that you probably
don't commonly do.
Now, this is something
that I commonly
do because I'm
helping developers
like yourself make this work.
And our sample code uses a flow
known as a client secrets flow.
Where you create a file
called clientsecrets.json,
you forward someone through
a web flow, and after someone
authorizes your channel you can
make API calls on their behalf.
Now, this is good for a lot
of types of applications.
But if you're doing
something like a bulk loader
this is not going
to work very well.
And the reason is you might
be running on a server
where you don't
have a web server.
Where you cannot simply
redirect someone to a web page
in a browser.
Now, there's a fairly
easy work around,
which is that you can use
system.out.printline to print
out the authorization
URL, copy it
into your browser on your own
computer while you're SSH'd in,
and copy paste it back.
There's another flow which could
make this a little bit easier.
Which is that instead
of writing the code
to go ahead and help you
generate the refresh token,
you can do this using a tool
called the OAuth Playground.
Now, I've showed this
in different shows
before because this is an
infinitely useful tool.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is quickly show you
how to generate a refresh
token in the OAuth Playground.
So first off go to
the Google API console
and create a new project.
Now, this is the
new Cloud console.
And you'll see it looks really
different from the old console.
So I'm going to go ahead
and click Registered Apps,
and I'm going to go into my app.
I've created an
OAuth 2.0 client ID,
I added a client ID
and a client secret.
I've also force
added a redirect URI,
I've set this to
developers.google.com/oauthplayground.
And the reason I've done
this is because we're
going to do our authorization
in the OAuth 2.0 Playground.
And after authorizing, we
want Google's API servers
to say, yes, this is OK to send
you back there with the OAuth
code.
So now I'm going to go
to the OAuth Playground.
I'm going to click
on the Settings icon.
And I'm going to scroll down to
Use Your Own OAuth Credentials.
I want to make sure
this is selected.
And that once it's selected,
that these credentials here
match up with the
credentials that I've
created in the API console.
I'm going to close this.
Now I'm going to select
and authorize APIs.
I'm going to scroll down.
I'm going to select
the YouTube scope.
I could use the sample
with just read-only scope.
I'm going to click
Authorize APIs.
And it's going to put me
through three legged OAuth flow.
I'm going to go
ahead and Accept now.
And this is going to give
me a refresh token as well
as an access token.
So now what I'm going to
use is the refresh token.
So I'm going to copy this.
Note that I'm going
to need three values.
The refresh token, the
client ID, and client secret.
I'm going to need
these in my code.
Now, let's go ahead and
switch over to My IDE.
Now, those of you that
have used Java before
know that you use a YouTube
object, you use a builder.
The builder you pass an HTTP
transport, a JSON factory,
and a credential.
And once you have that you can
just start making API calls.
It's the credential
bit that's the hardest
part to instantiate.
So I'm going to go ahead
and demystify this for you
guys today.
I've created three variables.
Client ID, which corresponds
to my client ID, client secret,
same thing, and refresh token.
And this refresh token the
value that I've gotten again
in the OAuth 2.0 Playground.
I've just copied and
pasted this value in.
Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to create a new
credential object.
And to create a new
credential object,
I'm going to use a new
Google credential builder.
I must set the transport,
which in an HTTP transport.
And this you only need
one instance as well as
a JSON factory.
I'm setting this to
a Jackson factory.
These are defaults that we
use in our code samples.
I'm going to call,
Set Client Secrets.
And I'm going to pass the
client ID as well as the client
secret.
I'm going to call .build.
Now, this pattern, you
see this a lot in Java.
This is known as
the builder pattern.
And I want to say
it's popularized
by Josh Bloch's
book, Effective Java.
So if you're writing Java and
you haven't read that book yet,
I highly recommend you do.
There's a lot of great Java
code patterns in there.
So I've created this
credential object.
Now I'm going out to
set the refresh token.
And I'm going to call,
Set Refresh Token.
I could also call Set
Refresh Token here
because this returns in an
instance of Google Credential.
I just feel like this version
of the code read a lot easier.
And it's easier to
understand what's going on.
So we return the instance
of Google Credential.
And that's all we have to do.
Now, I'm going to go
ahead and run this code.
Now, this code is just the My
Upload Sample that's available
on our GitHub site at
github.com/youtube/yt/samples/java.
So I've taken out all of
the authorization code.
So this is the bare
code right here.
I'm going to click Run.
And you're going to see that
there's a little bit of a lag.
And what's happening is
the Google API client
for Java is exchanging the
refresh token for an access
token that it can use
to make API calls.
And what's really
great is that your code
will manage this for you.
The client will
manage this for you.
In that if you do get something
that's expired, it'll go ahead
and it'll refresh
the access token
and get you a brand new one.
So that's what I have
for you guys today.
And just to recap,
this is a way to get
around having to build an OAuth
three legged flow yourself.
It doesn't save you that
much time, to be honest.
In fact, once you
generate a refresh token,
no matter how you do it.
Be It in your own code or
I running a sample code,
you can use that refresh
token using this technique.
And what's nice about
that is that you
can run the refresh token,
you can run the sample code
on your local machine.
You can save the
refresh token that
saved in wherever the
credentials are cached.
In the samples example these are
cached in your home directory
under, I think, .credentials
you can find those.
But once you have a
refresh token, in your code
you can always just load the
refresh token from some value,
be it a database or just even
a constant, to be honest.
Although a database
is probably best.
Because this way if you are
refresh token, for whatever
reason, becomes invalidated,
say through an account merge,
you can just go ahead and
put in a new refresh token.
That's the reason
you probably want
to read from database and cache.
So you can do that.
And you don't ever have to worry
about shipping code that also
has a three legged
OAuth flow in it.
So this saves you a
little bit of code.
And I think, in my opinion,
this clean things up
and make things a
little bit more clear.
So that's all I have
for you guys today.
Thank you guys for joining me.
And I hope that these
tips are useful.
So happy coding.
Take care.